I think what I've really been interested
in is I'm trying to make the government
work.
Uh,
I'm impressed with how big and how
complicated this country is.
Uh,
when I graduated from high school,
we had 130 million people in the
country.
Uh,
today.
I don't know what the figure is,
but I think I saw a few months ago that
we now exceed 300 million.
In other words,
in my working lifetime,
the country has more than doubled in
size,
but much,
much more than that.
It is become extremely diverse as a
country and how you keep this country
together,
uh,
whether this nation so conceived and so
dedicated can long endure is Lincoln
said it got us Berg.
It,
that question was the operative question
that got us a bird.
It's still the operative question,
whether we can keep this country
together prosperous,
peaceful,
free,
uh,
is the challenge.
And my passion I guess has always been
to,
to see how I can contribute to making
the country work better.
Uh,
I think a lot of things in American life
and American society that a disturbing.
We have a marvelous country and,
uh,
we've been given a marvelous heritage,
terrific resources,
great opportunities.
And I don't know of anyone who lives
here who wants to live in another
country,
and I know millions of people who live
elsewhere who would like to come here.
So you begin with gratitude,
I think,
for what you have,
but you also have to recognize our
shortcomings.
Uh,
we have a political system today that's
not working very well,
just defeated an immigration bill.
We cannot figure out how to give
healthcare to everybody in this country.
Uh,
we have an education system that is
deficient in so many ways that,
uh,
constantly come to our attention.
The infrastructure of the country is
crumbling in many respects.
The institutions are not working as well
as we would like them to work.
So I think the challenges are immense.
Now,
I don't look at all of this and conclude
it's hopeless or I'm a pessimist or
anything of the sort.
But I do have a real sense of the
challenge.
And neither am I starry eyed optimist.
Uh,
you see a lot of people who,
who portray a kind of a false optimism
that is not based on fact really,
uh,
in,
in the problems that we confront.
So I just liked the traditional hard
headed,
pragmatic,
old fashioned approach of Americans who
see their country in their community as
it is,
and they want to make it better.
But I don't see how any American can be
comfortable with our healthcare system
today.
Uh,
given the fact that so many of our
citizens are not covered here.
We have the most marvelous medicine in
the world if you can pay for it.
But so many Americans do not.
There's a janitor who comes to my office
and,
uh,
cleans it and,
he's a nice man.
Uh,
his teeth are falling out.
I go to the dentist,
uh,
I get a bill $500,
$1,000 for a routine checkup.
I can pay that fortunately,
and I can pay it for my family.
Here we are in the United States of
America,
richest country in the world,
and we can't get good dental care for
the janitor.
I'm disturbed by those things or take
education.
Today.
I used to go to high schools,
give speeches.
All the times politicians do.
I'd look out over that high school group
and we'd had an interaction.
My fractions may not be right here,
but 50% of those kids I don't need to
worry about.
Uh,
they come from good homes.
They go to their churches,
they have good healthcare,
they're involved in their community.
They may not all be a students,
but they're doing well.
Many of them are a students and we're
not going to screw those kids up.
They're going to make it and they're
going to do well in life.
What bothers me is that other half.
Now,
there was a time when we were so good
and so strong and so powerful as a
country,
but we didn't really need to worry too
much about that other half.
But that's changing now and we've got to
begin to bring them up.
And that means the educational system
has to be sharply improved.
So I worry about these things and many,
many others who,
who can possibly be comfortable or
satisfied with the performance of the
United States Congress today.
I don't care whether you're a Democrat
or Republican,
we cannot solve the immigration bill.
They took up a bill.
Not wasn't a perfect bill for sure,
uh,
rejected.
But we,
we have a huge problem.
We can't solve it.
And these other things we haven't been
able to solve.
So I think we have a failure of
political leadership in the country.
And I don't put that in the context of
the George Bush presidency.
I put it in the context of the last
several decades.
This system is not working as well as it
should.
And I began this program,
I said that my interest was in making
the country work.
And it still is.
And I think the challenges ahead of us,
sorry man.